thank you
artificial intelligence and machine
learning have been integral to my
30-year long I.T group but it has never
been under the umbrella of a design
program which I believe is very
important to solve various business
problems now that I've joined a new
company I think that the certification
can really help me there
I realized there were certain gaps in my
knowledge which I was able to fill hey
I'm Tony bigna I live in California I'm
currently working with the multinational
Consulting Department as a Solutions
architect in my 30-year long career I
have headed several organizations and
led multiple teams my last company was
PennyMac where I was senior vice
president there I worked extensively
with AI and ml Technologies I developed
machine learning models for
opportunities in Mortgage Banking I
decided to take the course to test
myself and fill any knowledge gaps I
took contacts ctmes AIML boot camp
offered by simply learn the overall
experience with simply learn was very
good since I'm a working professional I
really enjoyed the flexible schedule the
classes were on weekends and did not
collide with working hours so it was
really helpful overall the platform is
pretty well done and The Learning
Experience is good the best part about
simply learn is that they take feedback
on a regular basis and work on it to
improve the learning experience for the
students while taking the course I
realized there were gaps in The Way We
Were approaching things at work and how
we were using AI in some of the projects
the certification helped me fill those
gaps now I feel that I have a
contemporary skill set which is really
good for my profession I learned a lot
about python Keras tensorflow and other
machine learning libraries and
techniques I plan to use these skills of
my current job as well I like to play
golf in my free time I believe it takes
a lot of patience and hard work to make
a master stroke in golf and the same
applies to one's professional career